do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what is up everybody we are back
another saturday
it's a vfx saturday it's a good saturday
welcome everybody to the saturday
morning vfx live stream now today is a
little bit different we're not doing vfx
today um i got some big announcements
for you all this has been a long time in
the making
we got background music this time this
is the first time i've ever had
background music we got sodamonte in my
ear
he's uh the original moderator on the
discord server
um
it's been a crazy year and a half what's
up everybody good to see y'all good to
see y'all on the chat here
um
it's been a crazy year and a half it's
been a really crazy year and a half i
rebooted this channel a year and a half
ago um
and i've finally come to the point where
it's time it's time to step it up it's
time to go to the next level
so
during this stream it's going to be a
shorter one but it's going to be a fun
one because we got a lot of cool stuff i
want to talk to you about so i'm
releasing a patreon today's the day it's
live there's a link in the description
you can sign up right now we got five
patrons i believe as of this moment we
got my boy d von williams we got test
subject we got toby arturo and that one
ginger you tolerate that is that
person's name um
so shout outs shout outs to y'all this
is a huge moment this is a very big
moment it's been 15 years
since i started making youtube videos
and you know i kind of want to get into
a little bit of story time on like how i
started and how it's come to this point
and of course what the patreon is what
that means for you as a viewer for you
as a fan
um you know whether you want to help
support on the patreon or not like it's
all good i'm not trying to force
anything on y'all i just want you all
know about what's going on and how
excited i am about it so i'll talk about
what the patreon is there's two tiers
very simple um very straightforward
and um
yeah and then after that it's gonna be
question time you ask me some questions
we got a really cool new super chat
feature that soda
um he monte
he is now the
he is the what would you call it the
stream producer he's hooking it up he's
gonna make this stream better and that's
like
part of the reason why i'm starting this
patreon so
yeah we're gonna get into it we're gonna
get into it um so where do we where do
we begin where do we begin
so it's been like i said 15 years to get
to this point i started out making
videos on youtube um uploading my grand
theft auto stunt videos just like my
sickest stunts in grand theft auto
and i put them together and i remember
my buddy marcus he was like hey you
remember
he was like hey not do you remember he
was like have you heard of youtube
in 2006 and i was like
i think so what is that he's like yeah
you should probably upload
some videos sounds cool and um
i did yeah i did i put up the grand
theft auto stunt videos and my brother
had a picture camera like a little
digital camera that had like a video
mode that i started
shooting videos on my friend bobby
showed me how a video camera worked and
he showed me how you can cut from one
shot to another and it just blew my mind
so
he also told me that i had windows movie
maker free editing software built into
my computer
so i just went to town i was like let's
start making some cool stuff let's start
testing things out seeing what i can
shoot i as a kid i was super into like
military stuff and airsoft guns so i
would you know make gun videos and i
would try and add muzzle flashes to
you know to the guns and like it
basically it went on for about a year
and a half right and i shot a bunch of
silly little test videos and skits and
stuff um got into 3d at the time
and started messing with cinema 4d
release 10
and i got my first million view video
it was like a a video of like a old like
like a mini gun
just a spin around like a minigun
and if any of you remember that
oh my goodness that's about the oldest
fan i could possibly have because
all my videos got wiped
because i accidentally left myself
logged into a public computer and i
noticed my videos were gone and all the
descriptions were typed in like
you're dumb you're stupid
x y z
and i was like dang that's
that sucks all my videos got deleted
what
what am i gonna do
like that was cool i was getting into
youtube you know it was working
[Music]
but i realized at that moment that
like i can use this as an opportunity to
start over
and i can use this as an opportunity to
to
you know push myself to make better
videos so i was like you know what the
slate is clean all right
so
let's start making some better videos
so that's when carbo warfare started
coming along that's when you know the
kill zone extraction video the stalker
short film all the live action stuff
that i was like
man i just really want to get better at
this i love creating and i was getting
better at vfx andrew kramer was popping
off you know videocopilot.net
it was crazy yeah it was crazy and i'm
looking at the chat now and hopefully
the f's are for the videos getting
deleted versus like you not being able
to hear me
[Music]
so
i really took it as an opportunity to
step up
and
i realized that if my
videos are just vfx videos just vfx
reels
that has nothing to do with like a story
that has nothing to do
with like
you know telling a story and moving
people
you can have a fancy vfx reel but at the
end of the day it's just a vfx reel you
know what i mean
so i'm i literally i was in college at
the time i was in the technical school
um chattahoochee tech in in georgia
and about a year and a half in
um
you know freddie freddie wong
a great great friend of mine you know we
were fans of each other back in the day
and he was like dude you should move out
to la
and i was like you know i would love to
i had visited uh freddie sam and nico
and jimmy previously for about a week
and
i was like i would love to i would
absolutely love to let me ask my dad i'm
still in college hey dad can i drop out
of college and he said absolutely not
you need to get your degree and then you
can do whatever you want i was like all
right
all right
so
you know like any any kid would do you
know you ask dad and then you ask mom
but in this case i asked my teacher and
i was like
hey mr mason
[Music]
i have this opportunity to go out to la
and
pursue my filmmaking passion
and
you know it'll be a kind of a paid thing
kind of like i'll be able to live for
like really cheap he's like yo if you
have the opportunity to go out to la
and
you have the job
just drop out and go because the whole
reason we're all here at this tech
school is to go and get a job in la
basically and i was like okay so i told
that to my dad and he was like you know
what
that makes a lot of sense go for it and
i was like what what
really
he's like yeah go for it that makes
sense and i was like wow dad that is so
cool of you i was not expecting
i was not expecting
for you to say yes so i packed my old
toyota camry it was 89 camry the by the
way 89 camry is the number one stolen
car because any toyota key will work in
an 89 camry
and uh
yeah later my car got stolen at a later
point anyway um i packed that car full
of airsoft guns military gear costumes
like everything i had my cat noah and
like i was seriously i was scraping
across the united states all the way to
la
it took me 36 hours i did it in two
18-hour stretches i got to la
i went to in-n-out that was like the
first thing i did met up with some old
friends because i used to live in chino
hills
and then
it went straight to hunter street and
freddie was like just laughing like dude
what is this your car is ridiculous
you're scraping across you like your
bumper's about about to fall off
and it just starts like from that point
on it just started like a whole new era
of me leveling up
you know and
back then i wasn't thinking about
patreon i wasn't thinking about like
you know an audience i wasn't really
thinking about any of that stuff i was
so young i was 19 and
you know
i just wanted to make cool stuff that's
all i wanted to do was make
cool stuff
so that's what i did
i just hung out with freddie i hung out
with brandon sam and nico were starting
corridor digital at the time it didn't
exist quite yet
and
you know i was working on carbon warfare
2 doing vfx helping freddie and brandon
out with their vfx on their stuff i was
just learning learning learning
and
you know about a year and a half
goes by of that
and
freddy starts rocket jump he starts
video game high school
and
he's the reason i came out to la was to
hang out with freddie and to like
learn how to be a better filmmaker learn
how to make movies learn how to be a
better vfx artist
so i stuck with freddie he started
rocket jump i was like let's go man he
wanted to hire me to to be at rocket
shops let's do it heck yeah
so
we did it
we did it and you know i was a full-time
rocket jump employee
it was amazing i was getting you know a
salary with benefits and everything
it was like a real job a real actual job
and i was able to direct short films do
vfx you know act and fun stuff i was
shot bought in video game high school
and
you know
basically
that's a that's a good that's a good
place to pause it's a good place to
pause because we have mr one deduct with
the super chat
and we got the wheel spinning today
you just patreon tier one congrats dude
congratulations when the duck you got
the first wheel spin uh sotomante put
this together
it's just as a fun bonus for y'all
um he's got the he's got the roulette
wheel spinning real
it happens you know it happens
roulette wheel eight options
you can win a number of things three
things you can win in those eight
options we got patreon tier one patreon
tier two
the only two tiers we got another wheel
spin
george
thanks for the super chat
what you got
os 15 push-ups time is 15 push-ups time
all right dude
let's get it thanks george
all
i right this way
[Music]
thank you george
feel good
david bloom snap
15 years let's go
the 15 more thank you david
i appreciate you
you got that wheel coming up i think
hopefully good
george
one dead duck
so one that duck just won patreon tier
one
um contact soda monty on discord to
claim all the stuff giving away endless
concrete pack and everything too
um party popper yo
we got some party poppers today
we got some party poppers
heck yeah
all right uh who do we got who we got
david this one's for you
uh i got a limiter on it
but hey watch your ears just in case you
know what i mean
[Music]
a little smoky
um nice david good stuff
good stuff we got another one
we got another one we got two more my
goodness the steve show
hold on compositing academy super chat
at eight bucks
we got another party popper or is that
the party popper i just did oh my
goodness i don't know
compositing academy
another party popper my goodness it's
going off
here we go
boom
it's the steve show
with another super chat spinning the
wheel what do we got today 15 squats
let's do it let's do it
[Music]
well who else
lost
at least though
who we got draw something draw something
okay
all right i'll draw something
i think that was 15. i got to start
taking notes hold on
actually hey soto could you uh
did you help me out here i need the cue
we need to we need to get a cue going 15
more squats
i don't want to miss any of these
sodamonte help me out here give me a q
let me know what's next all right
[Music]
y'all
what's with the workouts today
oh my goodness
oh my goodness
ugh
oh good
okay
what else we got patreon tier one
david
david congrats patreon tier one for you
man
good stuff
you just won patreon tier one what is
the patreon tier one we're gonna get
back to that story time
these super chats are popping off right
now y'all are amazing
thank you so much adam what did you just
get draw something i got two things to
draw
today keep that q going i don't want to
forget what we got here okay
hunter hunter hall
that's a familiar sounding name i think
i know that name
what we got dude what dude
hunter yo
you're making me healthy i appreciate it
oh boy
patreon's here too
congratulations
it's the steve show you just won patreon
tier two
that's a 30 bucks a month situation but
you get a whole bunch of crap
i'ma go over it
the link's in the description
peter
thank you
thank you peter
brush russian oh yo
why
oh my god vj my goodness
15 more push-ups
no
ah
please no
thank
you dylan thank you dylan last time i
did this i blew out my kneecap
i just blew i did too many jump squats
on the stream i told myself i would
never do that again
this is a workout live stream man
oh
i get to draw three things
i gotta draw three things all right
y'all
chill on the super chester now just give
me a sec
give me a sec dj
i see you
working peloton class right now my god
no no no thank you thank you thank you
vijay you just won patreon tier one
congratulations
freaking awesome
congratulations vj let me get into these
into what this actually is i don't want
to miss any super chat so y'all hold on
now
hold on there will be time to super chat
oh is that endless concrete what is that
party popper
we're doing it rob this one's for you
i got like six left
but this one
is for rob thanks rob
boom
boom
thank you rob bj's back at it again
what's going on
what's going on vj endless concrete yo
congratulations
you just won my freaking latest concrete
pack that's sick
um it's just like 10 amazing
huge to massive scale
concrete textures all pbr comes with
normal maps specular diffusion for your
huge concrete renders
you got that contacts automotive i got
four things to draw
mill appreciate you
um sodamonte
where are you at soto
all right he's got the he's got the q
going
if we can start crossing some of these
out
i know i got four things to draw
okay it looks like we're chilling out
now all right and i don't don't forget
now
where we at where we're at in story time
okay so i just
just joined rocket jump with freddie
and that's starting
like we're at we're a little story arc
here all right so that's where we're at
in the story
let me get into what this patreon is
though first all right
so all right all right all right where
are we at
rob coming back with another
super chat
throwing it down much appreciated rob
you got yourself another party popper
dude these parties it's it's hype it's
time
it's party popping time
[Music]
just rip the darn sticker right off it
you know
zach
what you got zach another party popper
you all loving these party poppers right
now i have to clean all this stuff up
we got four party papas left
[Music]
that one was for you zach joshua what's
going on what you got today
water i'll drink some water
i would love that thank you so much
i love water
water is good
water is great
[Music]
okay what is this patreon
that
everyone keeps winning
what is this patreon well let's
let's find out let me show you
everything we got going
on this patreon
tkw
see josh
getting it with another super chat we
got it queued up for you
i'm gonna get into this uh disc or into
this patreon congrats dkw
josh you just won the endless concrete
texture pack i'm super proud of it super
proud of how it turned out that was last
week's video i showed y'all how i put
those pictures together
ariel
the chats don't stop
oh my goodness
y'all are great
you just won the concrete pack congrats
congratulations
um sotamonte
the moderator in my ear the eyes in the
sky if you could just
write down who is
okay
yeah okay okay okay um patreon tier one
hunter
congratulations you got that tier one
patreon community
community patreon tier let me tell you
what it's all about we're gonna pause
the roulettes for now
and we'll get right back to it all right
i don't want to forget anyone i got five
things to draw we're gonna draw five
different things all right
shout outs to fun house fan
so here's here's what we got community
tier so
first big bit of news is uh the discord
from this point on basically at the end
of this video
the discord
will be limited
to anyone
signing up for the discord for the first
time if you are already part of the
discord
or if you're not a part of the discord
you have until the end of this stream
join the discord the link is in the
description it's a massive community of
like 33 000 artists ready to help you
out do some fun challenges together
share your work with them get some
inspiration it's a it's an incredible
community um
you know we've built this up over the
last year and a half since i started
doing these live streams and it has been
incredible it's been an incredible
experience
so for the community tier
um
you get basically
access to the whole discord minus
there's like a little professional tier
section
um that's just for the pro tier but
basically the server as you know it
if you basically uh
have never signed up for it
that's what it would be we need to hear
but yeah if you're already on it you
have to worry about it you're already
getting like grandfathered in
to the to the discord i'm not taking
away anything this is just for new
people coming up
um
and for those people for those new
people coming up uh there is a free
version
where you can participate in the weekly
challenges and uh talk in the general
chat
but you can see everything else you just
can't type or anything but yeah it's
full access to weekly challenge and
general chat
so going back to the community
tier here you'll get ad-free videos so
all the videos i post on my youtube
basically as i put videos out i'll
upload it and add free version
to the patreon because you know
sometimes you just don't have time for
the mads you know what i mean
and finally uh a
full complete post archive of
all of the posts and blogs that i do uh
you'll unlock basically all that stuff
so that's the community here it's just
uh you know a way to say thank you and a
way to you know basically get you all in
the server
having fun um and it's been crazy
building us building this discord server
over the last
year and a half is grown i've never
expected it to grow to 33 000 people
um the moderators have done an
incredible job shout outs to all of you
um let me see if i can get off the top
of my head we got sodamonte
diren
uh we got mdk we got sipo we have visual
we have
i know i'm forgetting something we got
ronin
and is that and we got connor so shout
outs to all the moderators um who have
really made the server special
so
the professional tier
let's say this drop down so the
professional tier kind of where it's at
because this is where you get this you
get everything
so all my cg assets all my packs like
the the endless concrete pack my hdri
pack my surface imperfections and every
future pack to come
those are just going to be uploaded to
the professional tier for free so just
you get all that i'll be uploading all
of my photo scans all of my textures you
know everything all the stuff i'm
testing like i have a new hdri pack
coming out a little bit later
um
a new surface imperfection pack like
i'll be uploading those things to that
professional tier sooner than you know
before it's actually out before the
whole thing's out and when it does come
out i'll upload it in its entirety
for free of course um
what else project files all my project
files minus third party stuff obviously
i can't give you like mega scans for
free because that would be
that would be that would not be good for
me in terms of the epic game side of
things but yeah all my project files
like c4d files fbx files my dynamics
machine my dynamic machines file i'll be
doing like my alternate realities
parallel dimensions
all that stuff after effects files
anything for you all to like open up and
dig into and pull all the stuff you want
from
i'll be giving that to y'all in the pro
tier we got a pro tier art review so
basically every single month i'm going
to pull from a i'm going to randomly
select five artists from a pool
um
and review their art like in private
it'll be the five of us i guess six of
us including myself
and each person will bring up their art
and one talk about it and we're gonna
like break it down in fine detail
um you know here on the live stream i do
the art reviews like the weekly
challenge reviews
and those are
those are very like general quick kind
of things like oh this looks really good
i love this
you know and maybe like this one thing i
would tweak this one thing and that's
about as far as it gets this art review
would be like a you know
20 minute per person kind of thing where
we do a video chat and we talk about the
art we talk about what your goal was
with it and like little tiny things that
we can get into to like
just get that art to the next level so
that's what that art review is for the
pro tier we're gonna choose five artists
every single month and be in like
basically a small little class together
and like
you know just talk about art and see how
we can improve it
we got behind the scenes videos so i'll
do uh currently on there right now i
have like uh we're coming soon is a
lighting setup so i film my lighting
setups how i position my lights my
c-stands
my uh my my duvetyne like the light
blocking material
um how i get certain setups and
everything my audio visual setups those
kind of behind the scenes videos i'll be
posting all that on the pro tier you'll
get early access so usually when i film
a video i have to essentially like
uh
i have to write it out i have to type
out i type out all my scripts all my
videos so i'll upload like a script form
and then i do a vo version i you know
deliver the vo edit edit it together and
then there will be essentially like a
podcast version of uh
a
an early access like audio lesson
essentially and then once the pre-edited
video is done bam early access right
there before it gets to youtube so i'm
giving you everything as it comes out
right
uh we got the secret podcast so
sometimes there are things and lessons
and bits of material that don't make it
into the final videos
and i take that and i just talk about it
in like a podcast format
um so
that'll be like a bunch of extra you
know unreleased chats on all things 2d
3d and filmmaking and like a little
secret podcast format for the pro tier
we got 25 off all my limited edition
prints uh get them for a quarter of the
cost
i'll be releasing a couple more limited
edition prints very soon here probably
in the next couple weeks we got written
credit for you all so anytime i do a
live stream you'll see written credit
everyone on patreon here um or a
pre-edited video right at the end i got
you got you guys with that written
credit and then finally like i talked
about the exclusive discord channel so
we're gonna be hanging out we got the
lounge we got ask me anything we got
game night we got art review and
and uh the weekly challenge ideation
where
basically the pro tier
patrons will get together and choose
three prompts for the weekly challenge
from there the community will get to
vote on
what they want to do for the weekly
challenge
so that's how the weekly challenges are
working that's the pro tier that's how
it's going down
so
it's pretty crazy let me show you real
quick
what we got
so i've been kind of building this up
over the last month or so um you all
been asking for the project files we got
project files for
both tiers here parallel dimensions
dynamic machines and alternate realities
um just got it in one easy place for
y'all this should be free this is this
is open to the community
um but right here it's is right here we
can post on the discord as well
um i got you with some questions you
know i'm going to be wanting to know
what you will all want to learn and how
you want to grow so these kind of things
help me figure out
what tutorials you want me to make that
kind of stuff you know you kind of help
shape the future of the channel here
with with these different polls and
whatnot um my hdri warzone pack is up
of course
um
this is another poll like i'm asking
what question what what programs you
want to use that way i can figure out
again
where i want to dive into what tutorials
i want to do and like where your
interest lies and i can cater a little
bit more towards that
we got the massive
endless concrete material pack of course
you know looking super nice looking good
we got the surface imperfections up of
course
um i uploaded the lut which is a lookup
table that's basically something that
you can use to color grade your shots
this is the one i use for the alternate
realities
render
and we got a secret podcast number one
talking about color correction versus
versus color grading developing your
taste and problem solving in 3d
and finally a little story time here
15 years of youtube and i feel ready now
feel ready i do
and i think uh
let's get back to some story time
because i didn't finish my story
um
so i think sodamonte we can go ahead and
bring the bring the roulettes back i
think we're good um
talisto
good question i see ya um thank you for
the super chat are you allowed to use
professional assets commercially yeah
just don't sell my packs
but use them in your stuff like use them
for your work use them to do your client
projects whatever you know make some
cool stuff with it
um as long as you're not taking it to
like
rip it and sell it
then absolutely
you should definitely use it for that
kind of stuff so
all good
and i'll probably have a little thing
there for uh what does that call it's
like a
cco or coo or something like that
licensing you gotta look into it but
yeah use it for your use it for
everything use it for all your stuff
okay
so let's get back to it here
let's get back to it
where are we now let me recalibrate
bring up the chat
bam
all right
so
[Music]
we got 937 people up in here y'all are
great
thank you so much
thanks for joining me
doing it big we got the patreon
announcement today link in the
description
so
where were we at
story time so um
i moved to la i dropped out of college
and this is probably this is 2011. i'm
19 years old
and i moved in with freddie
and we're making videos together
and cg novice just hit me with the super
chat amazing
15 push-ups
it's good it'll get the blood flowing
we'll get into this story time heck yeah
15 squats i read squats
i read squats do squats
all right yeah rockman just won the
endless concrete congrats contact sipo
on discord
uh info in the description claim your
prizes
i think that was 15. man you got more
squats y'all come on
i know i can't blow my knee out again
adam what's good
what is good water i'll drink some water
i would love to
dang we might have to pause the we need
to pause this roulette again this is
this is getting intense
ariel
yo
amazing i'll drink some more water thank
you ariel
you say the next challenge should be a
vehicle traveling across the landscape a
simple box shaking jumping reacting to
unseen landscape we design
that is a good idea
that's a very good idea i like that a
lot
thank you for the water much appreciated
all right
primex
glad you're enjoying it
patreon tier one for you
congratulations primex you got patreon
tier one welcome to community
thanks for hanging out um
you got a month of it one month everyone
win the patreon sub is just like month
only
um
good times good things
so all right back to story time we can
pause this pause the roulette for now i
want to get back to some story time and
then we'll get into it well
we'll do it big all right so
basically
where was i so
[Music]
there's a transition between
me doing my own youtube videos making
cardboard warfare doing cardboard
warfare 2
making the killzone videos dead island
wolfenstein
and then all of a sudden like work
stopped coming in
and
i took a job at rocket jump with freddy
and those things kind of like
happened around the same time
so
i kind of got bummed you know i was like
it was a mix of feelings i was excited
about being able to work with freddie
and
take a full-time job
to direct and to act and do vfx and
stuff
but at the same time there was a part of
me like in the back of my mind and i
didn't
i felt like i knew it yeah i knew it
that i felt bad
and guilty for like leaving my channel i
felt
like man if i would have just stuck in
with it like
maybe the work would have kept coming
um
and even if the work wasn't coming if i
still stuck in with it like
maybe just maybe like i feel like i was
giving up on myself a little bit you
know so
and it's a very it's a very interesting
feeling
it's very is conflicting it's certainly
very conflicting
um but you know i moved forward i moved
forward and i continued making videos at
rocket jump having a good time with the
crew over there
um
and you know at the same time i was
thinking like you know on my channel i
would love to be posting on this on my
on my channel
why can't i do that well it's like costs
a lot of money costs a lot of money to
be able to make these short films and
do all this kind of stuff like making
making videos making movies
is about one of the most expensive
things you could possibly do
it's very labor intensive as well so
much work goes into making movies it's
ridiculous just just from the writing
standpoint it can take
years to write something
good with multiple people too and then
once you go once you write it you gotta
find the money to source the money to
like pay for locations pay for actors
pay for props to be made pay for
everyone's time
pay for editing pay for visual effects
pay for sound design pay for color
correction
you know pay for a composer
pay for you know these name actors and
all this stuff is very very
very expensive
and a lot of work
and there's just no way
that like
i could do that on my own but but it's
weird because like before with carbo
warfare i was doing it on my own
so what happened in between there did my
did i raise the bar so high for myself
that i couldn't keep up
that kind of did happen
where i told myself i want to put out
like the next video i put out has to be
better than the last video i put out
and
i think ultimately that kind of ended up
shooting myself in the foot
because i raised the bar so high i
couldn't raise it any higher
[Music]
inside like
personally i i want to keep raising the
bar but it got to the point where i just
financially physically
you know time wise was just not possible
to do
and
you know so the rocket jump situation
really worked out i was able to work on
larger short films with budgets and push
myself as a director and a writer and i
learned so much there as a writer and a
director at rocket jump that was huge
that was like the biggest thing i
learned from
from matt and will
on how to how to actually like
how to write how to truly write
and the importance of story you know
um
how you can't just have a movie
ran by visuals it needs to have a story
and it needs to be driven by character
so
i hear you on the music
i hear you on the music i lowered a
little bit hopefully it sounds good
sodamonte has a music sound
um
thanks y'all first time doing music here
i think we change in
ancient albums
alright so
where was i here
basically
at rocket jump i learned the importance
of story
and how it is the backbone to your movie
your short films all that good stuff
[Music]
um but eventually time at rocket jump
came to an end
um kind of ran out of funding and
and um
you know after that basically after that
like it was
no one really wanted to leave but
um
i felt again once again
this is my chance to make it on my own
again
so i try to get into freelance i try to
do freelance i was always doing vfx jobs
on the side
um
but this one at this time i don't know
it just didn't work out it didn't work
out the job step stopped coming in and i
got really stressed out really anxious
about things
um i wanted to
you know do things on my own again but i
just couldn't i didn't i didn't have the
means of doing so
uh and there's actually perfect timing
because nico reached out and he's like
dude you should join corridor we'd love
to have you and it was a no-brainer for
me it was like you know what let's do
this
this is this really is a no-brainer
um
so i joined the corridor crew and i was
there for three years another three
years i learned so much i learned i
became the best vfx artist
i've ever been at corridor along with
ren sam and nico and the whole crew
there but it was really it was like
myself
sam and ren pushing each other to the
max
constantly when it came to vfx i learned
how to
oversee
larger projects from a vfx standpoint
how to organize vfx shots and dish them
out to certain people to make sure they
got done on time all that good stuff
um and just from the boss town dynamics
videos like that was some that i just
said still is my best bfx work was the
boxtown dynamics videos
i also learned how to run a youtube
channel
from sam and nico and jake like they
really
they do a good job they do a really good
job over there
very small things like the importance of
thumbnails how how important thumbnails
are and how that is the
gateway um for your audience into your
videos and if your thumbnail just blows
then no one's gonna click on it
i gotta i gotta up my thumbnail game for
sure that's for sure um but again that's
what the patreon helps with so
just a note with the patreon like
i'm kind of going back and forth here in
the story but basically
doing everything on my own now i've been
doing it for about
six months i think i've been out of
corridor for about six months
and
i feel i have maxed out
my
effort
on
uh my like i've i've maxed out like all
the things i can do for this channel
now that doesn't mean i'm not making
videos no that just means like
i am doing this alone i am writing i'm
shooting i'm editing i'm doing sound
design i'm coloring i'm coming up with
the ideas i'm like
what else i'm doing the marketing
answering the emails trying to get like
brand deals uh setting up you know
setting up patreon doing the discord
luckily i have the moderators to help
but like i'm doing everything on my own
and i cannot physically do any more it's
too much it's too much i'm at the point
where i'm maxed out i'm red i've i'm
redlining and i've been redlining
while i was at corridor i was doing
these streams
so i was working like two jobs at once
and i've been redlining ever since
and
this patreon my goodness oh thank
goodness
patreon is a way for me to like start
paying people
paying editors um visual one of our
moderators he edited the last two videos
i did shout outs to you man like it's
it's going well it's going really well
sodamonte he's helping out with the the
live streams now so i want to have a
live stream producer and help make these
streams better basically
the patreon is a way for me to help
start paying different people
to
really build up a team that could assist
me on this channel to make videos better
for you to make the community better for
you to just make everything better start
getting more people's time to focus on
the cool stuff we're doing here so
that's what the patreon is going to
allow us to do together
um compositing academy thank you for the
super chat says hey clint been working
for months on an effects pack with 200
energy effects my goodness
biggest on the internet
uh would like talking about partnership
if interested my background his way to
ilm film industry dude hit me up on uh
hit me up on discord
hit me up on discord um let's see what
we can do yeah it sounds really cool
sounds super cool
thanks for the super chat shout out to
tia
so yeah um
you know it's gonna be a way for me to
to build up a team this patreon and
really focus
all of the creative energy into this one
place
um
and allow me to buy myself some time
so that i can write better videos so i
can
basically shoot better videos and my
plan is to make a movie that's really
like making a movie
and
teaching people all the different things
i've learned along the way is such a
priority and a passion for me
so that's that's where we're going you
know we're we're doing all this 3d work
we're doing all these drawings like i
got to do some drawings for y'all we're
doing all this 2d work we're doing all
this vfx creative work
to tell a story to tell a bigger story
and i want to tell a big story
so
you know in a couple years
three years i don't know when
my first movie comes out fingers crossed
i want to be able to just fill
this channel and the patreon with
a closer look on how to get a movie done
and i'm going to be learning a whole
bunch
like i am going to be in it oh
it's going to be intense
but
i don't know it'll be cool to do it
together that'll be sweet that'll be
sweet
heck yeah heck yeah
so yeah that's kind of that's the
patreon um that's the plan that's the
goal here i'm gonna keep making videos
i'm not i'm not stopping to do anything
no it's like i just i just
it's all exciting stuff it's all
exciting stuff y'all i think i've i've
said a lot i've said a lot at this point
so
what do we do from here i can answer any
questions you all have
any questions that you all have we can
bring the roulette wheel back
i'll answer any questions we'll do a
little ama situation it can be about the
patreon it could be about the future it
could be about personal like whatever
um just at me so i can look for the at
punishers here in the chat um it makes a
little bit easier to read things
drago lord yo um
i will have fun no matter what
i will
you know i love challenging myself
and stepping up to the next level like i
always
i don't know i've always been hard on
myself
personally um
but
i don't know maybe it's my martial arts
background it probably is my martial
arts background i did martial arts for
about 10 years and really enjoyed the
hard work
and the payoff that comes from doing
that hard work
and i know that if i work hard things
will pay off
um
what else we got some other questions
here
let's see martin next semester we're
gonna do 3d graphics in c4d and what i
learned from you about i'm gonna be
ahead of everyone else so thank you
absolutely martin heck yeah i'm i'm glad
that you uh you learned a lot from this
channel or at least one or two things
that's great man ben what's up
when is the render competition with
ren's awesome marble loop i hadn't
figured out the schedule yet someone new
to these streams ben welcome to the
streams great question yeah so um
dynamic machines
that is the render challenge that we did
last month it ended about a week ago
it's going to be dynamic machines for
the rest of the month it's going to be a
hoot the whole rest of this month next
week i'm announcing the winners five
winners
from the dynamic machines challenge
shout outs
to pny and nvidia by the way
for sponsoring this challenge and
hooking up with some awesome prizes so
we got um
top three
i was wrong with the five winners we got
top three for
us and we got top three for
international so technically it's six
winners
um
and we got some graphics cards to give
away we got some super fast ssds to give
away and i'm giving away patreon
pro tier
for a year as well as some limited
edition prints as well for my
international audience so that's going
to be next week the week after that the
21st is going to be the top 100 dynamic
machines render montage and the week
after that on the 28th is going to be
the all renders montage we're looking at
about four hours
of awesome renders from y'all it's going
to be incredible i can't wait
all right
i think i just i think i just did i just
miss a roulette
little monty what went down
oh we got brandon kang
dude
shout outs to brandon kang
good to see man i just missed your
roulette but yo
sodomonte's gonna let me know what's in
the chat
little monte what did brandon king just
hit
shout outs to brandon king
his um super cool dude super freaking
awesome dude he makes really cool like
music video style videos and uh
he is a a big nft collector this dude is
legit
shout outs to you man um awesome to hear
your story again and watch personal
endeavors come to fruition super excited
for your projects and what you do for
the community man shout outs to you
patreon tier two that's what we got
heck yeah
bk
got that tier two patreon
congrats dude
i mean you're gonna get it anyway i was
gonna give it to you anyway but
congrats dude thanks for the shout outs
let's see what are the questions we got
here
see
hey ali good question very good question
so how do i balance work and
life
yeah kim's laughing
it's a hard one let me honestly that's a
very difficult one i can i have a
tendency to just like work work work
work work i'm a workaholic
um
i really love it i enjoy doing it but i
can't work forever because i know that i
will eventually burn out at some point
so i gotta have that work life balance
and i know that it's gonna be a thing
that i'm gonna have to balance for the
rest of my life i will always be in a
constant state of trying to find that
balance
um
you got to do what's healthy you got to
take time to
take breaks
get some workouts in go on vacation
spend time with people you love
i just i i mean
we're working at it you know we're
working at it
like i said constant state of balance
always in it always in it that's a very
good question
bj a man
you are throwing it down
with the super chats man
thank you so much that's very kind of
you
thank you thank you thank you
vijay you got the wheel spin what you
got today
and i can't remember what you won so i'm
gonna say it like you just won it you
know what i mean
draw something i gotta draw stuff let me
get up in here
let's get into photoshop let's draw some
stuff
[Music]
all right um we're answering questions
we're drawing things
we're giving away
some fun stuff patreon tier one tier two
and this concrete pack we're giving it
all away y'all helping me with the water
with the push-ups with the workouts it's
a good time
answer more questions let me let me draw
something and we'll answer some
questions
what should i draw though um
like a pole
[Music]
what should i draw we got um headphones
we got um
sam porter bridges
action
figure this is all from my desk
um what else do we got iphone
i'll leave it at that
[Music]
what should i draw
[Music]
render warrior what's game night on pro
tier good question game night on the pro
tier
patreon is a way for me to like hang out
play mario kart play smash bros play
chess play uh
um spy fall whatever kind of video games
we all want to play just hang out and
play some games so that's what game
night is
we'll get some games going maybe we'll
get some leaderboards going get us some
smash tournaments popping off
saipo
one of the moderators throwing it down
heck yeah man
that's great this would be awesome to
tag along with creation your movie make
it maybe not like a vlog but more like a
documentary yeah
we're gonna do some cool stuff i want to
be able to teach you guys as much and
i'm gonna be learning you know it feels
a little weird to teach you how this is
going when i'm learning it at the same
time we're gonna just figure it out
together that's how it's gonna go but i
got 15 push-ups for y'all
rockman
i see you okay
[Music]
rock man you got a
patreon tier two congratulations for one
month baby let's go
heck yeah any tips for someone who wants
to get into 3d but has no creativity oh
come on
you got some creativity
you got to find uh what inspires you
what you gravitate towards what shows do
you like why do you like those shows
what games do you play why do you like
those games
what's your favorite color
you know um
go outside observe you know observe some
stuff do some people watching
hang out with friends who get your mind
spinning and moving a little bit
it helps a lot listen to music that gets
you inspired
huh
oh yeah and don't be so hard on yourself
that's what kim says don't don't be so
hard on yourself who we got what four
horntow thomas you got patreon tier two
congrats got it for a month
absolutely amazing
absolutely amazing
all right i think
sam porter bridges action figure wins
the drawing so let me pop this off real
quick
all right let's get him in position
this is from my buddy devon
i'm just going to do this from
off the top of the dome here
no sketch no nothing we're just going in
all right sam porter bridges how are we
going to do this
so if you keep everything in the same
style
then
your drawing's going to look good
if you keep it uniform you know
[Music]
right now this probably looks a little
chunky
but
[Music]
here we go all right got the head going
let's i'm gonna just block this all out
getting that block out
[Music]
get that canvas size up
[Music]
all right
see we got like a box what we got
box like right here
all right let's see
we got a bunch of uh
a bunch of boxes up here carrying a
bunch of stuff
[Music]
out out sasha drink water thank you i
will do that adam too
thank goodness patreon tier one for you
shout outs shout outs adam
welcome
congratulations
let me get that block out that general
block out of everything
and i'm really looking at some i have
this character on my desk here
and i'm really looking for
where these pieces lie in connection to
each other
[Music]
oh let's see what this look what sasha's
question is uh how many submissions were
there for the dynamic machines challenge
i hope i actually submitted mine
there was just under 2 000 submissions
for the dynamic machines challenge a
bunch of good ones um
i went through them all so far i'm gonna
do another pass on them
um
and we're gonna choose the top choose
the top 100
uh what else
yeah the the the full submission or the
full uh
challenge itself
full montage rather is
four hours long it's gonna be four hours
so pretty freaking sweet
[Music]
motivation when
studying the basics and you feel bored
well
not all of it's going to be exciting you
have to prep yourself for that
that not every not every thing you do is
going to be a blast
try and just get into the zone
that would be my that will be my piece
of advice for you spidey
is to try and get into the zone focus on
what you're doing
and and find a nice rhythm
[Music]
i really want to do some blind contour
drawings
on the stream
and get pictures of y'all and and draw
everybody i think that'd be really fun
[Music]
foreign
i'm looking at this drawing here i'm
looking at this figure trying to figure
out where everything
placed
steven what's up steven
i want to make some 3d forms of the
characters i've made tips on programs i
should try out my style sort of
cartoonish anime vibe
hmm
3d forms the characters made doesn't
blender have like a
i might be way off on this but doesn't
blender have like a grease pencil or
something like that where you can draw
cartoony looking things and then rig
them up and animate them
i'm pretty sure
all right let's see what else do we have
we got the foot knee pad
[Music]
i always found a
difficult to draw
i feel like am i am i missing uh the
wheel
vt snap i missed the wheel what vt get
litamonte
thank goodness i got sodamonte up in
here
what'd i miss
let me also move my obs window over a
little bit
there we go
all right 30 push-ups that's what i got
i got 30 push-ups
i'm gonna wait
i'll get official confirmation
all right so he's carrying a little
briefcase here
you know it's kind of fun because like
3d
and and 2d drawing really help each
other out and go together
oh snap vt my goodness
motivated because your videos that's
amazing
uh you do blender add-ons like sim uh
simply cloth and dude how many push-ups
you hit me with
oh my god
i got
45 push-ups to do bt you're killing me
oh i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna
i mean i'm not gonna
not do them i'm gonna do them
45 push-ups i believe y'all
i believe y'all
all right here we go
we got 45 push-ups
let's pop it off
let's do it
okay this is for you right here
oh
oh my goodness
slummy belle
thanks for the super chat thanks for
making high quality 3d workflow videos
well i need to take tips of 3d hey wow
that means a lot
that means a lot
dylan
uh soto what'd you say
patreon tier two
i gotta drink water
we got tier two congratulations
winning big
and i appreciate the water
[Applause]
thank y'all back to it sam porter
bridges
all right
he's got like a
little baby thing coming out off to the
side here
these are just primitives
a bunch of primitives
oh adam
what you got adam
what you got here
patreon tier two adam congratulations
you got it for a month
that's sick man
super sick heck yeah so you really want
to get into digital art what advice can
you give when attempting to bring ideas
into reality
i can see uh the castle but i don't know
where to place the bricks
good question wow very good question i
guess
familiarize yourselves yourself with the
tools you have
and the tools you need so really all i
did
was i just watched a bunch of tutorials
when i didn't know c4d at first i just
watched tutorial after tutorial
i watched it on the airplane i watched
it in car rides and i just
picked tutorials that
i knew i would you know want to do what
they're teaching me and
just get amped get amped on them
tutorials
download them bring them with you watch
it
um
and and that you're gonna build up your
arsenal it's like you don't know what
you don't know right so you need to
build up your arsenal of tools and
tricks and for me that's just watching
tutorials watching tutorials and get
excited about it because you know
you're leveling up every tutorial you
watch you level up your ability
and from there
like oh you can do anything you want if
you technically know how to do it you
can make anything you want if you see it
in your head so
yeah just keep watching tutorials
um
and you'll get there we'll get there
[Music]
[Music]
oh mill
spinning the wheel
patreon tier one thank goodness it
wasn't the push-ups
congrats nil if you've won tier one
already and congrats you won it again i
guess
i guess we will limit it to one to one
month
um and andrew k spinning the wheel right
now i see you
i get
if i get push-ups you'll do them but yo
you just won tier two
andrew
congratulations pro tier on patreon for
a month it's gonna be sick
can't wait
um but let's see what these uh comments
are saying do i have any advice for
college freshmen interested in the world
of film
man that's a big question
that's a very big question what did i do
well let's see i um
well try and get on try and get on some
sets you know i do i did some extra work
back in the day
um
and seeing how a big old set works like
that is so cool
so try and maybe get into some extra
work so you see if you can get on some
big sets
um and see how they work and just start
making contact start making contacts
hang out with people
work with people who
um bt thank you for the water much
appreciated
start thinking about uh
you know making different contacts
hanging out with genuine people
um
and surround yourself around people who
inspire you who can potentially get you
some work
and kind of go from there
up
um pa on sets you know it also depends
on like what you want to do in film two
so
um
yeah start hanging out with those people
meet some good contacts stay away from
the from the bad people and
you know you'll figure it out
slummy bell with the wheel spin
getting that patreon tier one
now at this point
i can't remember if you won it or not
but congrats you got patreon tier one
good stuff
um andrew k i'm making my way down this
list of questions
um if i get push-ups you'll do them but
you got tier two thanks for all you do
in the 3d world and i look forward to
these streams and learning from them
heck yeah thank you andrew much
appreciated
david what you got
draw something
all right
i got five more things to draw after
this hopefully they'll be faster
i want to do these uh
these blind contour drawings i'll do one
of myself to show you what i mean as the
next one okay but i'm almost done with
this uh
with this sam porter bridges here we got
his little like
i don't know what this thing is called
is like a little seeker thing
there we go something like that
we get some detail on these boxes we
gotta draw his face at some point
um let's see
we need his legs
it's like knee pads situation
up in here who's spinning the wheel
sterling
throwing matthew party popper it's been
a minute
i could use a party popper right about
now thanks sterling
here we
go
boom
heck yeah
i needed that
vt is back
vt is back with patreon tier two if you
hadn't won it already it's about time
congratulations
bt
thank you
thank you thank you much appreciated man
you're going to enjoy it
um
guys this is incredible thank you so
much for all of this aviti says the
videos are epic and let you believe in
yourself heck yeah i wish you all the
best only the best for you in your life
i'm serious all the best you're amazing
thank you vt
i got another thing to draw
let's
see
uh itch itch thies
got me drawing stuff do you have any
advice for writing good dialogue for
characters oh my god
dialogue is the hardest yeah get
hold on i got a book for you huh
two books for you
it's these the first one
called dialogue
dialogue it's called dialogue it's by
robert mckee robert
mckee m-c-k-e-e
robert mckee
dialogue
read that book
and then
story
by robert mckee as well
read those books
this is like
the bible of
story and character right here these two
books read these books
[Music]
um
all right
uh let's see
what's the first thing i look for in a
sound designer sterling matthew well
does their sound design sound good
that'd be the first thing
um does it sound full
is it punchy
sasha
hit me with the draw something
we're doing it we're working on it
um thank you for the super chat you said
you were sad i left corridor but
otherwise the challenges wouldn't exist
i really like them so thank you for that
thank you sasha i appreciate you jordan
hitting me with that super chat
shoutouts to you man
draw something we're on it we're on it
here we go let me get these eyeballs
this is the hardest part
all about
looking at what you're drawing
don't guess
don't guess
look at what you're drawing
oh
thank you sotomante
that looks a little janky but we can
probably hit it with like
beauty of photoshop
[Music]
like that
feels pretty good to me
[Music]
wait
[Music]
wait vt
man with the super chats
thanks for the water vt
man
very very generous of you very generous
with vvt thank you so much
[Music]
ah felipe
we're doing it we're doing it i'm gonna
do a blind contour drawing of myself
next i can't wait to show you that it's
so funny
all right let's make some
some cases here
keeping everything in line
yeah i love drawing i really do
this is a very obviously a very quick
one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wait
[Music]
nice all right we'll color it in
let's do
something like a
let's see
[Music]
i got dark blue of sorts
we got a wheel spin
off compositions
what you got
party popper heck yeah let's go
do it
[Music]
boom
that one's for you
lost compositions
very nice
paco
patreon tier two congratulations paco
you got the pro tier a patreon for one
month shout outs to you man that's
awesome congratulations
congrats
all right let's get this uh
capacity
down get up in here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we'll get everything in the body
basically blued out
and then we'll come back for like the
darker stuff
maybe a little bit of shadow up in here
[Music]
we got christian 15 or 15 squats let's
go
this is coming out sick can't wait to
see everyone's dynamic machines next
week me too me too it's gonna be good
all right 15 squats for you
oh
heck yeah
good stuff very good stuff
all right let's get the darker color
going
make that darker blue
for the boots
and the knee pads
[Music]
sodamonte why would you do this
why would you do that to me
you're supposed to be on my side here
dude
oh my goodness
goodness why dude that's that's evil
[Music]
all right i'm gonna get you your
push-ups in this minute in a minute
go to monte
evil
evil
evil
so happy to see these preparing uh see
these days repairing the streams pay off
so wonderfully
the best and thanks everyone being on
the stream yeah seriously thanks
everyone on the stream
um
it's been amazing it's been amazing i'm
excited about this drawing this turned
out pretty nice all right i got 15
push-ups for soto shout outs to you man
thanks for running the stream
triangle push-ups triangle push-ups for
you
i got a mistake
[Music]
oh
oh that was rough
i was rough
vt
give me some water please
nope
no
no
oh my dreams are coming true right now
15 squats for uvt thank you
i know christian the form i know i
understand i understand you gotta watch
out for them elbows you know
on that blood shelf
oh yeah
oh yeah
all right so i made the mistake of
coloring over the lines
all right
let's get some orange up in here
i find the right orange
maybe something like that
no
deeper
dan madden
my goodness
shout outs to you
glad to see committed to yourself your
inspiration i'm only amateur freelancer
myself but i love the opportunity to
work with you one day
um even if it's for free
towards your film i'm gonna draw
something for you dan you have an army
of 3d dudes here
dan shout outs man thank you so much
this is very generous of you
thank you so much dan
i'm gonna keep drawing this for you man
shout outs to you
incredible
all right we got
this baby carrier thing is orange too
and technically this is orange down here
this orange blob
uh let's do
we got gold cases
shoot all right let's make this kind of
i do this
are all gold cases
do silver's more gold georgie
what's popping thanks for the super chat
let's see what you got today
patreon tier
two congratulations georgie
you got patreon tier two today
the pro tier that's everything that's
all the asset packs for free you got
endless concrete pack you got the
surface imperfections you got the hdri
pack you got all you got everything you
got everything for free
amazing congratulations
15 squats shaheen
this for you
oh yeah
all right
all right
[Music]
[Music]
i get those highlights going too
same reason you bevel your edges
highlights
[Music]
all right let's find a deeper orange
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right and let's get some skin tone
going
i could spend i could spend all day on
this
[Music]
[Music]
let's get that hairline too
nice dark brown
keep it in lines here you know
[Music]
i feel like the drawing
kind of rough
when we first start out but
if you stick to it
it'll look good in the end
keep your style consistent
that's it
[Music]
and looks like we got a highlight
nice soft brush
low opacity
and with that highlight
ah but i don't like that
i don't like that faded look
come in for
them eyeballs
[Music]
oh
highlight gotta get the highlight
sasha when's the next weekly challenge
coming good question
this week
today after the stream
thanks for the water sasha
you know i could have uh
messed with my layers a little bit more
down here
kind of janky that uh
the paint goes over everything but you
can maybe work that back in
there we go
and let's get it with some like
some of this business
the black brush
60 opacity
and we'll hit these bits here
now keep in mind i am not a graphic
artist
we got a wheelspin we got frelin
fingers crossed for the squats
how about that patreon tier 2 though
get it all you get it all
there's no squats so congrats prowling
congratulations man
winning some cool stuff today
i mean i could keep going but like you
know we got like a bunch more drawings
to do let's go
and open up
this is this is number one
i want to do a blind contour drawing
[Music]
so here we go
we got sam porter bridges he's chilling
[Music]
looking good
all right blind blind contour drawing of
myself how am i gonna do this um
[Music]
i know how to do this
here we go
[Music]
so here's the here's the rules i can't
look at what i'm drawing
and i can't pick up the pen
from
the canvas all right or from the from
the uh the tablet i have to do this
without looking i'm just looking at a
picture of myself
here
and we'll see what we can do
i love these so much
[Music]
[Music]
all right here goes nothing
[Music]
that's the eyebrow
is the other other eyebrow i think
[Music]
hairline
[Music]
hair i think
okay now this is where it gets way off
that's the ear i think
uh
the beard
and the nose
oh my goodness
i love these so much
wow
that's me
geez
blind contour drawing
so ridiculous i love it i love it i love
it
i would do this for everybody this is
what i wanted to do like if you get draw
something
this is this is what i want to do for
you you know
let's shade it
let's shade it
have it look really nice
15 squats from vj saying sam porter
bridges looks really good thanks for the
motivation and inspiration
this is for you
a 75 finished sam porter bridges bj i
got some squats for you
[Music]
oh 15 squats
why do i never sit i don't have time to
sit
all right let's see
we got some unread roulettes here
15 squats from let's see i got the water
from
relling
um
metatrox looking forward to the dynamic
machines challenge live stream
started in a uh started in 3d back in
poser 3d and animation master dude i
don't even know what those are i think
i've heard of poser but bryce i don't
even know what that is
that's crazy thanks for the super chat
and it looks like you got
patreon tier one congratulations
metatrox sorry i missed you
david
i feel like i got you some i got them
squats for you didn't i dude
i can't remember we got so many squats
these days
i want to make sure i hit them all
all right all right
let's see
[Music]
so that was the
this was my my drawing of myself without
looking i'm gonna shade it in
we'll count towards another drawing here
[Music]
all right so for that let's grab the
brush
look at that low flow
low opacity
[Music]
let's see light source coming from the
oh right
[Music]
this is this is absurd
hahaha
so
amazing
let's hit it with the uh
little bit of hair
[Music]
and that i light
listening
so
it's beautiful and it's terrifying all
at the same time
full kit a
shout outs man
have a good night
or
you're just telling me the time it's 1
15 in india it's late
that's late
what else should i draw here
um
or is it question time maybe it's
question time
been drawn for a minute
how's everyone doing thumbs ups all
around you guys doing okay
[Music]
we got how many people we got up in here
937 people up in the chat we having a
good time doing it big
watching from uganda crazy
crazy man that's awesome
guape
super legit
i'm out of water
[Music]
[Music]
so y'all have any questions for me
any questions on how the patreon works
on
plans for the future any of that good
stuff
um because that's about it you know like
it's a basically patreon announcement
stream giving away some good stuff do
some drawings for you all hanging out
with y'all nice little celebration we
got
how many more we got two more party
poppers to blast off
hang out with y'all for a little bit
um
we should definitely do a poll for the
next
weekly challenge
and
you know as this works out basically so
real quick y'all if you are not a part
of the discord server join it now
because
it's basically going to be
um like paired down for anyone trying to
get in for free
if you're trying to get in for free
starting after this stream
you're only going to be able to access
the weekly challenge
um channels as well as general chat
um
but hunter has got me with the 15
push-ups
let's pop it off
[Music]
oh
it's a good day
it's a really good day
avi sheck what's up from india
yo man
all right so
basically the way it works now
if you're on the community tier patreon
you get access to
the discord server as you know it
if you are already on the discord server
you're just going to get that anywhere
i'm not taking away anything from
anybody it's just new people trying to
come in
um they're only going to get weekly
challenge and general chat access
right so if you're already on the
discord
then you're all good no worries
um
if you're on the pro tier discord you
get like an extra set of channels for
pro pro channels or we get to you know
hang out play games
you all get to choose what the weekly
challenge prompts will be for the
community tier to vote on the three that
you choose we'll do it together on the
stream here right now actually so
might as well do it
let's start a new poll here
totally just realized you can do polls
which is pretty sweet
all right so let's do
a new poll what should we do for the
weekly challenge this week
i am taking suggestions
what do you all want to do
[Music]
so let's pick three things together
and then y'all are gonna vote on it and
that's what the weekly challenge is
gonna be for this week
bench design yo that's awesome
i'm glad you got into 3d man
super cool
ah
oh mdk yeah model and render sword okay
so sword
sword
model
it yourself
no assets
what's next
oh a blimp
originals chocolate world
i don't know about chocolate world
vaporwave
that's not bad
that's not bad i like that
visual halfway explosion interesting
tropical okay interesting interesting
ronin
opposite that'd be hard to do
vehicles train mirror
mirror could be interesting
storm
wires okay weather
[Music]
i'm gonna put vaporwave
as one of them for now
we'll see what else comes in
rainbows classroom mirror
myth i think miniature we've already
done
thrilling how do you claim your prizes
good question hit up sodamonte
on discord
connect with him um his his information
to connect this for everyone who won
something today
check the description in the description
you'll have um
instructions on how to claim your prize
right so you're going to contact
sotomonte on discord
his tag is in there in the description
check it out and get your stuff all
right and take care of y'all
um what else do we have
classroom half and half minecraft cubism
[Music]
coral reef
optical illusion
hmm
bob ross render ships
papercraft ooh
papercraft
origami maybe
what do you think about origami yeah yay
nay
library could be cool
what was this last one
i'm i think we've done time
pain
ah okay
mdk yeah that's a good one brutalism
an architecture style
i like to spell architecture
ac arch
arc
i think that's right
let me double check that
how to spell
architecture
all right good texture i had it right i
had it right all right i like that i
like that so we have
um an architecture style which is
brutalism which is like really
tall concrete
um
full shaped looking buildings we got
vaporwave and we have a sword
model it yourself
those are the three right now
i'm gonna do it here we go
bam pole is live
get it in
what do y'all think sword you want to
model a sword yourself you want to do a
vaporwave style render or do you want to
make a really cool architectural style
it's called brutalism
the answers are coming in
we'll leave it live for about a minute
so happy to answer any questions from
y'all i'm gonna give a shout out i mean
we can do this now when i started the
stream i had five patrons
minus the ones who want it for free
if i refresh this page hopefully i have
six
oh snap
we got
how many patrons we have
20
i'm gonna get some shout outs um
etienne
a teen
hopefully i'm saying that right shout
outs to a teen
very good stuff looks like you got uh
tier one congratulations marcus priller
shout outs to you
looks like you also have tier one
john schroeder
thank you sir pro tier for you gonna be
good good stuff composing academy
shout outs
i see you thomas
mcnamara
shout outs to you thank you thank you
oh we got jimmy page popping off he's
wanting me to draw something all right
we'll get you
i love seeing you succeed and doing what
you love on all the streams and
competitions thanks jimmy i appreciate
you man
connor mcneese
got that pro tier shoutouts on the
patreon dean wong i see you adam
thank you so much
donato
yo donato one dead duck up in here
shout outs got that pro tier
um i saw
faisal hopefully i'm saying that right
uh but shout out to you you got the pro
tier as well thanks for supporting y'all
are amazing
andrej
incredible ethan i see you stein
very good stuff
honor bowling thank you for your support
and it goes down we got my boy my boy
devon williams all the way from atlanta
georgia we got test subject toby t
arturo and that one ginger
one ginger
that you tolerate
that's their name
thank you so much thank you for the
patreon
support you're incredible thank you guys
for starting this
popping this off right we're doing it
big
heck yeah can't wait can't wait
all right so what's winning we got
for the weekly challenge it looks like
brutalism is winning right now and i
think it's going to be brutalism 46
percent of y'all we're gonna end that
poll
danny mccook
what's good you spin the wheel 15
push-ups
all right while i do some push-ups you
all google what brutal brutalism is
brutalism
and architectural style
big concrete buildings 15 push-ups for
you danny let's get it
you know what this music i'm feeling it
let's go
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
all right
i was feeling it
music felt good i gotta get the extra
five
push-ups in
shout outs all right let's figure out
what brutalism is let me google it for
y'all
really cool stuff on google here
look at this
super cool stuff
really sick if you got that uh that
concrete pack too that endless concrete
pack today is the last day for that 50
off
on the endless concrete pack if you want
to pick it up
um it's gonna be perfect for this kind
of stuff
absolutely perfect
really cool designs
this guy's chilling who's this guy i
don't know
but he's chilling
like this is so cool this kind of stuff
this kind of stuff
love this kind of look here big fan
very very big fan of this kind of stuff
so that's the challenge come up with
like a brutalistic style architectural
render
um have fun with it
it's gonna be sweet it's gonna be super
cool hunter hall can we model our scene
based off of a real-life building
or area because fermi lab is my favorite
brutalist architecture example and i
want to use it yes you can go for it
absolutely
um
i don't think there's any points
taken for
you know trying to recreate a building
or a certain style
or a very specific building but hunter
you just won patreon tier one
once again don't know if you want it yet
or if you won tier two but you got tier
one right now so congratulations contact
sotomonte
his contact info is in the description
okay so if you won anything if you want
the concrete pack or either one of the
patreon tiers contact sodamonte his link
is in the description contact him on uh
on discord
yeah literally the best architectural
style i agree visual
super cool
so yeah i think that's everything um
again
if y'all aren't part of this discord
community this incredible discord
community 33 000 artists on this thing
do it now because as soon as this stream
ends we're going to switch it over so
that
you can't get full access for free
anymore the only thing you're going to
get for free
is access to the weekly challenge and
general chat that's it
um
community tier is the full unlock of the
discord minus the pro tier channel
pro tier is full
plus that pro tier channel so
that's what we're doing um
it's going to allow me to essentially
start paying a team to help me with
these videos so i can free up some time
and start working on you know more
things adding more things to the channel
um we're going to start paying a stream
producer we got soda monte on here we
got visual
he's been doing some of my edits so we
want to build up this team of cool
people and uh and make it possible to
just keep making cool stuff do it
together so
nothing's changing we're just we're just
we're just rising we're just getting
better and better and better
i really appreciate you all left from
india from pool kit still awake
almost two o'clock
seems like a scam
max
you don't have to do it
like i'm not taking anything from
anybody
it's not a scam at all how how would be
a scam
um
yeah you don't have to you don't have to
do any patreon stuff not at all
absolutely not
um i'm still gonna be posting videos
here and it's just extra stuff that
you're getting that's all really all it
is it's just extra stuff if you're
already on the discord server then
you got you got the discord already so
no worries
yeah
um
so
where are we at if y'all have any
questions
happy to answer anything right now i'm
looking at the chat i see y'all
alberto
do i remember alberto
from like chino
like marcus alberto
alberto
so
it is a big deal for me to
be able to provide as much value for you
as possible
um and that's the goal
certainly don't want it to feel like a
rip you know
um
i wouldn't i wouldn't feel cool with
myself if that was the case
and i'm open to any suggestions you have
so
i want to you know grow this with y'all
make it nice
vfx king can you make interiors for the
challenge this week absolutely yes you
can
yes you can
what else we have um
any narrative style or theme you want to
go for in your feature yeah i mean i
colin that's a good question i uh
i love a lot of different kind of movies
and
i could make so many different kinds of
movies
so it really is at the pick which which
one i want to make and i really want
this one to be fun i wanted to have some
action and i wanted to have some comedy
um with also some mystery
right and i want to be serious
but at the same time funny so
that's what i want to do
exactly what i want to do
what else
um glamastro asks now that you can
literally learn anything
like with youtube and you know
skillshare and a bunch of other stuff
how do you put the line on what not to
learn if you enjoy most stuff
great question
very very very good question
so
to me it's like
i always i always do it like this right
now i know cinema 4d really well not
well i know i know it pretty darn well
there's still a lot of things i don't
know about c4d
now
i could either learn unreal engine or
blender
how do i know which one to choose
well
to me
since if it's like a venn diagram
i'm gonna just illustrate this
what's up y'all
freaking picture okay
um let me illustrate this real quick
so
let's say this is my knowledge
this is like c4d right this is
everything i know about c4d
and then you have
this is c4d
and then you have blender
which is a whole other skill set over
here
all right big old same size boom blender
and then you have unreal engine five
bam that's a whole other skill set right
so
i think
the blender to c4d thing is like this
they're so similar
i do a lot of the same things
i could spend 100 i could spend more
than 100 hours i can spend a thousand
hours
in each one of these programs
but if but if i spend a thousand hours
just to gain
this
right
versus if it was
if it was c4d and unreal engine
there's a lot less overlap
right
so if this if this is c4d
and this is unreal
for the same thousand hours i spend
learning a new program i'mma get
all this
so
that's what i ask myself
does
this new program i'm trying to learn
fill a gap in my
workflow
that's kind of it at this point you know
like i really want to learn substance
that whole world because right now like
my c4d world here
and substance i feel like is like
it's a whole lot you know
substance designer and uh and c4d
so i have a lot to learn on this angle
of things but like it wouldn't make
sense for me to learn
like
3ds max like why would i do why would i
do that you know it could be even less
so
that's my thinking on it you know that's
the way i think about that which
programs you want to choose for yourself
to spend the time on
what else we got any other questions we
have to wrap it up here
i'm gonna get some rock climbing in
and show with freddy
some old friends some old rocket jump
friends we're gonna go rock climbing
excited
can you use a live action picture in
your weekly challenge render i guess if
it's like framed on the wall i don't
know depends on how you use it
you can't just upload a picture and have
that be your submission probably
wouldn't win
um
what else do we have
any other questions
that looks like it's it
you're great thank you so much for
everything
um what a stream that was a really fun
one
we did cool stuff we did cool stuff on
the stream today um it was a different
change of pace
imma pop off these uh these last two
these last two party poppers for y'all
shout outs who we got
who's in who's in need of a shout out
right now
let's see
y'all malcolm you've been around for a
long time
i got a party popper just for you buddy
shout outs to you
thanks for sticking with us for so long
you've been part of this community for
almost a year and a half since it began
it was good to see you still in the chat
here man thank you for being an awesome
uh an awesome artist
and a cool dude so here you go this
one's for you john malcolm
[Music]
all right
john malcolm good good times
good times who else we got one more
we got one more party popper
to pop off
right here
who who's up late who's up freaking late
thanks for the stream compositing
academy
absolutely
um i'm looking for that wheel
did i miss it
chat was covering it
but hopefully it pops up
um
pop for everyone this is for everyone
yeah heck yeah i'm gonna pop off for
everyone
thank you guys for for freaking catching
these streams over the last year and a
half you've been incredible thank you
for being with me on this journey and we
have so much further to go so much more
to do so much more art to create so much
more to learn let's keep learning and
growing together this one's for y'all
[Music]
good times all around
um aggro bro
love you bro
edo i love you too
and we got vj again number one
aggro you just popped off with that
endless concrete congratulations use it
in the weekly challenge this week it'll
be great
it's gonna be so good
um and who else we got vj
thank you vijay
much love from you
i don't have any more water but i will
grab a kombucha
i will grab a kombucha
just for you
okay i'll be back give me
give me 10 seconds
shout outs
that's vj ginger ginger aid favorite
flavor absolutely
good times
good times y'all
i think that's it
i think that's it
um y'all are amazing
maybe we'll play some mario kart or some
smash bros on the stream next time but
next week next week we got the uh
dynamic machines announcement who won
pick the three us winners who are going
to win some cool prizes and the three
international winners we're gonna win
some other cool prizes okay um shout
outs to nvidia and pny for sponsoring it
dishing down those us prizes
it's gonna be awesome it's gonna be big
all right
all renders montage is looking like four
hours long
and most of you i'd say 95
actually did sound design that's
incredible
like i can't i can't ask that of of
people like who
can't expect that i have a fear like 40
maybe
you know
um but that's going to be sweet the week
after we got the top 100 dynamic
machines montage and after that
and out the month we got the all renders
so it's going to be a dynamic machines
not a month it's going to be sweet
thank you all no thank you thank you
everybody peace out
good times weekly challenge
get on that discord server join it now
if you're not already part of it it's
free to join full access right now as
soon as i close the stream i'm gonna
like drink this
and then i'm gonna hop in with sodamonte
and we're going to work the permissions
right
so get in right now if you're not in
it's free
full thing
all right y'all
peace out have a good one
much love
catch y'all soon
till next time
where's the where's the end button on
this thing i got too many windows going
uh-huh